et tout de suite l'invité politique de
la matinale ce matin avec nous jacques
alain bénisti mer les républicains de
villiers sur marne jacques alain bénisti
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin sur rtl france alors je vous
propose de débuter avec un point sur la
situation sanitaire plus précisément sur
la campagne de vaccination aujourd'hui
en france 1 c'est plus de 2 millions 900
mille personnes vaccinées à titre de
comparaison on a 15 millions à au
royaume-uni alors dans votre commune
très concrètement où est-ce que vous en
êtes est ce que les personnes
prioritaires elles peuvent se faire
vacciner aujourd'hui chez vous écoutez
la réponse va être brutale n'ont
aujourd'hui je dirais que en france et
vous ne dites pas vous les journalistes
à ses 97 % de notre population n'est
toujours pas vaccinées au bout de deux
mois où le vaccin était lancée c'est un
véritable casse-cou nous a mené en
bateau
moi j'ai essayé de me procurer les
vaccins comme un certain nombre de
maires en disant moi ces diamants préfet
je me débrouille tout seul
laissez-nous faire comme les basques
comme les tests etc
malheureusement ça n'a pas l'air le
préfet m'a dit si vous faites venir des
vaccins directement ils vous seront
saisis voilà donc aujourd'hui j'ai une
cinquantaine de personnes sur une
population de compte 1000 habitants qui
ont été vaccinées donc c'est un
véritable fiasco
et je dois dire que ça va de mal en pis
puisque on voit mais je dois mes
administrés essayer de prendre des
rendez-vous et les rendez-vous
aujourd'hui c'est vers la fin mars pour
simplement la première dose
alors justement le président de la
république s'est exprimé sur la
stratégie vaccinale c'était dans les
colonnes du journal du dimanche
regardez les pays africains nous
interpelle à juste titre sur leur accès
au vaccin
l'initiative a c'est ea aurait permis de
sécuriser plus de
milliards de doses de vaccins à bien
meilleur prix que si chaque pays les
âmes et négocier séparément
c'est en soi une réussite mais nous
devons encore accélérer les efforts car
chaque semaine compte alors vous nous
dites vous dans ma commune moi j'ai pas
de vaccin le président lui dit la
stratégie doit être mondiale pour que
les pays pauvres à puissent avoir accès
aux vaccins qu'est ce que vous me
répondiez aujourd'hui au chef de l'état
écoutez je pense que c'est toujours du
grand théâtre
je pense qu'on est on s'est laissé
embarquer par des commandes pour pouvoir
faire avoir des prix sur les vaccins
donc c'est sablic te manque on n'entend
pas souvent dans la filière c'est le
fait simplement le c'est une question
d'argent et qu'on veut payer des vaccins
qui vont sauver des vies simplement
s'ils le font ils ne sont pas chers je
pense qu'on se fout du monde dames
aujourd'hui je pense que les maires nous
sommes en train là et à blement de
prendre les choses en main et de faire
un ensemble qu'on puisse enfin se
procurer des vaccins
on nous laisse faire vous allez dire
comment justement vous allez faire
comment j'allais contourner la
préfecture vous avez contourner le
puisque ce que l'on veut faire et sauvé
nos populations l'état le président de
la république deux premiers ministres de
la santé sont aujourd'hui incapables de
protéger nos populations
donc il est certain qu'on doit se
débrouiller et la seule manière de pulse
et effectivement il ya des filières soit
qu'on paiera les vaccins de poids ou
trois fois le prix qu'aujourd'hui
l'europe nous les procurer
mais au moins on aura la conscience
tranquille d'avoir pu sauver nos
administrés parce que ça ça serait
quelque chose de simple dans les faits
vous avez étudié la façon de commander
des vaccins en parallèle de la commande
de européenne
on ne peut pas les commandes et puisque
l'europe étaient des règles peur avec
les laboratoires et on ne peut pas donc
les gronder des commandes et en europe
on peut les commander ailleurs quand
l'europe et
fr l'ip est directement dans des pays
effectivement où les la peau peuvent
envoyer ccvh axa se répéter au préfet la
dernière fois que si je n'avais pas les
vaccins avant la fin du pont et bien on
se débrouille tout seul et j'assumerai
les conséquences de ma décision
alors toujours à propos de la crise
sanitaire
si les élèves de votre commune sont
actuellement en vacances le ministre de
l'éducation a annoncé via un allègement
du protocole sanitaire dans les écoles
ça a provoqué des réactions a notamment
des syndicats à regarder c'est un
objectif qui reste absolument
fondamental et c'est une fierté
française que de maintenir les enfants à
l'école et de le faire dans des bonnes
conditions de sécurité sanitaire les
dernières études que nous avons qu'elles
soient nationales ou internationales
vont d'ailleurs dans ce sens elle montre
que l'école n'est pas un lieu de
contamination plus fort que le reste de
la société
c'est même plutôt l'inversé nouveau
protocole sanitaire assouplissement des
règles de fermetures de classes et
d'isolement alors que les variants
circulent davantage le ministère de
l'éducation nationale casse le
thermomètre quand la fièvre monte une
décision incompréhensible et
irresponsable alors à villiers sur marne
est ce que vous êtes inquiète la
circulation des variants notamment dans
les écoles ou au contraire selon vous la
situation elle permet effectivement à un
allègement des mesures ci est évidemment
que dans l'est
les variants sont présents mais je
dirais des quantités nettement moindre
effectivement quand par les villes de
comet s'est entendu mon collègue
grosdidier en parler et il a raison de
dire qu'il faut prendre des mesures
spécifiques dix ans pour la région
autour de même en ce qui concerne la
région parisienne on ne voit pas pour
l'instant une augmentation de ces
variants encore moins dans les écoles
alors la décision qui a été prise
d'aller c'est donc effectivement les
mesures qui ont été prises
c'est en dehors de la une fois de plus
qu'on questionne les maires on demande
aux maires des différentes villes six
passes dans leur commune on leur dira
effectivement ce qu'il faut ce qu'il
faut faire
vous n'êtes pas assez consulté toujours
on se souvient au début de l'épidémie
c'était une question de savoir si les
élus locaux étaient assez consulté le
gouvernement a dit on va davantage les
consulter par la suite c'est toujours
pas le cas c'est ce que vous nous dites
c'est pas et consulté on n'ait pas
consulté du tout différence de pas assez
donc si si on était huit mois consultés
ont d'ailleurs on a des rapports avec
les rs mais moi j'en veux pas aller res
lairesse subi les décisions aujourd'hui
du gouvernement on oppose souvent le
problème en disant les restes épars et
actif et la rs en fin de compte dépend
totalement du préfet le préfet dépend
directement du ministère de l'intérieur
et du premier ministre
donc les décisions qui sont à prendre
si on réunissait simplement les maires
notamment des des maires de la région
parisienne on expliquerait la réalité
sur le terrain et on pourrait proposer
un certain nombre de choses alors dans
l'actualité également ces dernières
heures la question des violences contre
les policières notamment avec cette
vidéo diffusée par des policiers on
entend des jeunes criaient tuer les tuez
les en lançant des mortiers et c'est
dans ce contexte qu'une phrase de la
défenseure des droits claire houde ont
fait beaucoup de bruit en ce moment
regardez et vous réagissez ensuite
est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas expérimenté
l'arrêt de contrôle d'identité dans
certains quartiers pour certains jeunes
cela devient insupportable dans 95% des
cas les contrôles d'identité ne donne
rien alors votre réaction à vider sur
marne par exemple est ce qu'il ya des
quartiers on pourra éviter de faire des
contrôles et ça pourrait éventuellement
calmer la situation vous en pensez quoi
une fois de plus je la vis tu vires dans
mon cas est sensible on lui expliquera
comment ça se passe pourquoi aujourd'hui
effectivement les les policiers ont du
mal à entrer à l'intérieur de nos cités
sensibles
si on leur retire le moyen de savoir qui
le regardent des pierres
qui les agressent hiller voie d il leur
envoie des cocktails il est quasiment
des bombes sur les forces de l'ordre
à ce moment là on expliquera madame est
donc comment on fait pour arrêter ceux
qui agressent des forces de l'ordre si
ce n'est par carte d'identité alors en
quelques mots il nous reste quelques
secondes l'assemblée nationale vote cet
après midi l'ensemble du projet de loi
séparatisme on a vu que la question de
communautarisme soulevées notamment dans
la ville de trappes ces derniers jours
cette loi elle divise pour vous est-ce
qu'elle pourra être un outil finalement
pour apaiser le quotidien de vos
administrés
écoutez on attendait beaucoup de cette
loi moi quand ça a été annoncé à prêter
en afrique
je m'attendais à des réelles mesures en
fin de compte la montagne accouche d'une
souris
toutes ces mesures étaient préconisées
d'abord curieux c'est que dans le texte
c'est de séparatistes hier à aucun
moment on voit le mot séparatisme dans
le texte
moi je vais présider la commission des
lois lorsqu'on parlait d'un texte on
vole un titulaire et il y avait à peu
près 30 à 40 fois le le mot de
l'intitulé du texte qui était dans le
temps dans les textes de loi
or là on l'a pas du tout alors je pense
qu'il faut faire en sorte d' appeler les
choses par leur nom
il ya un problème de communautarisme
politique islamiste existe ni gangrène
autour du tout les communautés
musulmanes
parce que les premiers touchés
aujourd'hui de ce communautarisme
valises ce sont d'abord et musulmans et
ensuite les mesures ils font aujourd'hui
à mon avis ne serviront pas à grand
chose
merci beaucoup réclament un ministre
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin dans la matinale je le rappelle
vous êtes maire les républicains de
villiers sur marne